I don't know dad I mean it looks like a
bunch of little kids live here it's nice
it's festive
it's like your own sad little Christmas
parade
[Music]
I heard you got out of finance it's a
system of monstrous greed and for what
more toys bigger houses so you have some
big plans
you know charity work that I'm you know
yeah which one do these diseases you
know and they can't cancer spectrum so
are you separated no I'm divorced do you
have kids yeah yeah I do have you even
looked for a job yet yeah I got one oh
you did oh yeah I did delivering booze
do you live here I didn't think this was
your style I mean what's your style of
delivering liquor
looks that way I just kind of hang gray
brood a little bit like the guy you see
sitting across from you right now oh
lucky me all of us wake up back let's
just the same what happened to you but
quit your fancy job something had to
change I made the same mistake Smith you
can't just come in here you're drunk
what I'm just getting some things man
everyone needs to relax a weird flavor
are you kidding me no taste like flowers
what is wrong with you Anders you are
the one who wanted out so get out
you know when I saw you at the window
just now I thought you were him I have
some questions for you
Preston did did not do anything I swear
to God I did not tell anyone how could
you not call us [ __ ] you might like this
you brought me an erotic stolen library
book yeah I'm sorry you have such a
disappointing dad okay
I set this vision my life was like a web
the more webs could have coming from you
than the more important but if you
vanish then the people that were in your
life
they learn to rely on someone else and
then the web just remakes itself and
moves on without you
you
[Music]
you